when you were writing songs essentially  for other people yeah I mean obviously  you just you enjoy the creating process  but did you have trouble giving up your  songs to other artists not really  you know I the things that I grew up on  and listening to I and I longed for this  day again I say this all the time to  people you know today were so precious  with songs and like oh well he's going  to record it nobody else can touch it  and but you know there was a time when  if there was a song that everybody liked  and they thought it was a great song  there before five ten versions of  different people doing it because they  thought it was a great song and I I  think that for me that still is true you  know like I'd like to hear other people  do things that I wrote because they're  always kind of interpreted differently  than I would and that's what artistry is